voir ce qu'il en est exactement parce
que j'avais entendu dire qu'il ya eu
quelques fois mais des fausses alertes
comme il n'y a aucun dégagement de fumée
dans la cathédrale il n'y a aucune odeur
particulière et qu'on voit encore moins
de flamme on voit vraiment rien pour
nous la situation est tout à fait normal
donc non je n'imagine pas du tout je
suis en train de se passer
au bout d'un moment on m'a persuadé les
personnes qui se trouvent d'abord au
fond de la cathédrale qui commencent à
sortir notre dame se vide peu à peu
pendant qu'un gardien part à la
recherche d'un départ d'un 100 dit qu'il
ne trouvera jamais personne n'appelle
donc les pompiers
pourtant le feu couve bel et bien dans
les combles loin des regards juste sous
la flèche alors en restauration
il n'y avait plus de fidèles touristes
donc on était peut-être une vingtaine
dans notre dame c'était vide et on
discute presque de choses et d'autres
évidemment de ce signal d'alarmé que
l'on considère intempestifs 30 minutes
30 précieuses minutes sont donc perdu
avant que les pompiers ne souhaite
alerter
en face de notre dame à l'hôtel de ville
la maire de paris est l'une des
premières à comprendre qu'il se passe
quelque chose je suis assis à mon bureau
mon directeur de cabinet est en face de
moi on discute détendu et tout d'un coup
je le vois s'arrêter net dans son propos
et me montrer la fenêtre du doigt et je
vois une petite fumée mais toute petite
fumée qui sort de la flèche de notre
dame est vraiment dans ma tête
notre dame ne peut pas brûler c'est un
petit truc c'est sait rien du tout ça
mais quand même je dis à ma secrétaire
mon assistante je lui dis appelle tout
de suite quand même les pompiers
veuillez patienter les services
d'urgence reçoivent beaucoup d'appels
championnat cause
oui bonjour monsieur je travaille à
l'hôtel de ville de paris et une
quantité de fumée totalement anormal
s'échappe d'église notre gamme c'est de
la fumée noire à devenir un meilleur
pointage on va révolutionner oui bonjour
je suis à paris et je vois des femmes
sur le principe maître d'armes d'un
important dégagement suez sûr que notre
ami qui a le feu à un autre d'avancé
aux premières loges les riverains film
et s'inquiètent
[Musique]
[__]